Americans spent an estimated 445 billion
dollars every year on beauty products
that number is expected to hit 750
billion dollars by 2024 the popularity
of internet influencers as forcing
beauty brands to change their marketing
strategy media vdl met one group of
influencers called the founders club who
become startup beauty brand CEOs they're
calling their own products and sharing
tricks of the trade collectively these
women have more than 5 million people
around the world following their every
move on Instagram are you working on
your packaging now these influencers are
adding the title of entrepreneur to
their profiles the idea that you have
several very successful women sitting in
one place at one time like supporting
each other it just doesn't feel like
that happens often we genuinely like are
here to help each other and support each
other and help our brands grow
hey guys Marianna here welcome back to
my youtube channel today I'm here at the
Lory really think like collaboration
over competition and we want to help our
friends and our fellow influencers and
just like kind of help lift everybody up
influencers like Beauty entrepreneurs
Mariana Hewitt and Lauren gores Ireland
made money by sharing sponsored posts
collaborating with major brands or
incorporating ads into YouTube videos
what I don't think of you guys have
actually tried Kerastase is laying crab
cream Suzanne can post something and
it'll push more sales than an actress or
someone on a TV show but now these
self-made celebrities are launching
their own skin care makeup and
subscription box services and creating
competition for bigger more traditional
brands you don't have the science
background so then what makes you
qualified to launch a beauty brand we
call ourselves educating consumers and
because we've tested and tried so many
things out there we knew exactly what we
liked and what we didn't like in a
product so we worked really closely with
the lab and formulated a product from
scratch and we didn't launch it until we
were fully happy with it are you fine
some good options cat Quinn refinery29 s
beauty director says these women offer
something many of the big beauty
companies don't hi guys I just signed on
to live direct interaction with
customers what they are experts in is
they're experts as consumers so they
know what their followers like they're
talking to their followers in the
comments being able to kind of tap into
this focus group that's like at your
fingertips all day long and this is by
Tasha Wynn says these influencers aren't
just convincing people to buy products
one line we love is beauty counter their
force in the industry to shift their
strategy with a modern-day Avon lady
so it's like your friend that would come
into your house and then put all the
products on the table and hope that you
bought something when you left it's the
same but it's online now moving in this
way it's a tiny bit you would and gore's
already had a trusting engaged following
when they launched their skincare line
so how do you go from influencing to
then creating your own product was it
because there wasn't something specific
in the market that you wanted for
yourselves we had a relationship with
our followers and they were telling us
every day what they wanted so we took
what we wanted to create and we took
what they were asking us for and then
dreamed up the perfect product I mean we
have not spent any marketing dollars and
we were able to become a number one
selling skincare brand even possible you
didn't spend any money on marketing he's
all social media it was all social media
and you're so excited to finally share
with you our next product for summer
fridays and it's almost more convincing
for them to buy from a youtuber they
love then an ad in a magazine from
Instagram to instant success
right before we launch it we'll bring it
to our medium and you guys can well
because I think that this group is proof
it's good to be light for CBS this
morning media via Los Angeles